hey this is this is bad this is really
really bad it's been difficult enough
trying to get Republicans to get serious
about the possible connections between
Donald Trump and Russia and recognize it
as a potential problem but we finally
got the House Intelligence Committee to
conduct an investigation one of two
congressional investigations of the
Trump campaign and whether or not they
colluded with Russia this is aside from
the FBI investigation which we now know
exists thanks to James Comey telling us
that on monday during his testimony so
okay we've now got these two
congressional probes that are in good
hands right working in earnest to
honestly find the answers right well
maybe because it has now been revealed
that Republican congressman Devin Nunez
the chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee he's in charge of leading the
investigation if you've been paying
attention to the news every few days or
once a week or I don't know how often he
will take questions about the status of
the investigation he told a mother Jones
reporter this week that he has never
heard of Roger stone or Carter page 2 of
the key figures in the Trump Russia
scandal the guy leading the Republican
that the the Republican leading the
investigation by Congress into this has
never heard of two of the key people
involved with this pseudo or possible
potential scandal here's a tweet first
from David corn saying nunez just told
me he's never heard of Carter page or
Roger stone and he's in charge of the
investigation here is Devin Nunez
talking to David corn from Mother Jones
I haven't heard of car to page and all
these other people
I mean is there about five names notion
by the net I don't know they even if
you've not heard of for the pain or
rogerstone you've never heard of men
afib you've never had any stories but
any of these people know I've heard lots
of stories but there was more names than
that David corn said and you could see
this in the background of the video we
just played if you were watching that
there were reporters listening and just
shaking their heads in disbelief that
the guy running the investigation hasn't
heard of two of the key people if you're
hearing me say this and you're saying
well but David I haven't heard of Carter
page or Roger stone okay I mean I
suspect many in our audience at least
Roger stone they've heard of but we're
talking about the person in charge of
investigating this who presumably has
been receiving countless high-level
briefings about all aspects of the
scandal hasn't heard of Roger stone and
Carter page pat it reminds me of Gary
Johnson's what so fo moment yeah if
you're just someone sitting at home who
is relatively interested in politics
right follows current events you may
still not know what Aleppo is and where
it is sure but if you're supposed to be
leading the investigation I think that's
kind of important I'd say yeah a little
bit Pat with an understatement it's kind
of important to know who the key players
are in this thing of course Carter page
foreign policy advisor to the Trump
campaign who met with Russians during
the election Roger stone Trump campaign
adviser who was in contact with
WikiLeaks and the hackers that hack the
DNC recently admitted to this on Twitter
these are two of the most if not the two
most important people at the center of
the Trump Russia scandal and Devon nuñez
is in charge of the house intelligence
committees investigation into the
scandal you'll remember that during the
coma hearing Nunez also didn't really
seem to care about what the leaks
related to the Trump campaign and Russia
said instead nunez like many of those
Republicans was concerned merely with
how should we punish the journalists who
leaked stuff which is pretty common Pat
whenever you see leaks the content of
which people don't like they instead
only will focus on how should we punish
the leakers even if we're talking about
journalists who actually legally will
not be punished for that they have to
find some way to go on offense here
because if you're just defending the
whole time it looks like you have
something to hide or that you have this
week or
have a point of your own but they were
not willing to adopt the claim that
Trump made that Obama wiretap Trump
Tower right I guess this was the option
they went to this was the one and so
focused that they could take during
these hearings to create some optics
that take away from the fact that
there's no evidence to support trance
claimed that Obama wiretapped him and
that there is indeed a very serious
investigation at the highest level into
collusion between Donald Trump and
Russia so there it is we i don't
remember i think it was yesterday during
a youtube live stream i got a super chat
question asking me whether i trust that
the that james comey will be carrying
out a full and decisive investigation
into the Trump Russia scandal and i said
no i don't i absolutely don't put my
trust in Devon Nunez in carrying out
what I would consider to be a thorough
full and unapologetic investigation into
Trump and Russia and the fact that he
hasn't even heard of two of the key
players involved in this only supports
that what do you think about this i'm on
twitter at d pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show follow us
both and tweet me your thoughts